hello I'm Emily Furman i'm a freelance
data visualization designer and
developer as well as a master's student
in the Department of English and
comparative literature here at Columbia
so the work I do focuses on building
data-driven visual systems across a
range of different contexts both static
and dynamic and independently i'm
interested in experimental approaches to
data visualization dissecting
perspectival constructs and leveraging
non digital mediums to encode
information and I'm going to take a
slightly different approach to my top
today in that the data I'm talking about
will be smaller and fuzzier and I
simultaneously want to examine
visualization as a practice that
produces a certain kind of artifact
so just start I'll just clarify exactly
what I'll be talking about in terms of
uncertainty and ambiguity because those
are both by nature not clear things so
at least my focus and my subject matter
are on the clear side
as a practice data visualization rests
on visual disambiguation given the tools
that we have that disambiguation tends
to take the form of points lines and
polygons or other more inventive
combinations of clearly delimited shapes
and visual elements
and while formal approaches to
representing the values of a given data
set are integral to giving it a
graphical configuration what I want to
address today is the importance of
critically adopting a set of visual
conventions that relies on demarcating
any sort of boundary but especially when
focusing on visualizing qualitative
relationships and on a related note the
techniques and ideas I want to speak
about I think gesture toward a broader
need within the visualization community
as a whole to more frequently visually
acknowledge the ambiguity that inheres
in the whole data wrangling process from
attribute operationalization to a final
polished visualization and I feel like
those conversations tend to take place
more often in geo visualization than
they do in non geophys realization
so i lumped qualitative relationships
and uncertainty together because both
are ambiguous and with that in mind I'm
going to address Lee broad
interconnected areas first I want to
talk about the nature of the space that
visualization as a practice constructs
which is associated with but not limited
to conventions tied to web-based
contexts second I want to talk about
some practical approaches to
accommodating uncertainty when
visualizing data less as some sort of
exhaustive summary of all of the things
you can do and more to point towards a
couple of techniques that would prevent
you from necessarily like washing out
differences in a data set even though of
course as visualizers that's what we're
inclined to do
and finally I want to share project I
worked on within the past year for which
accounting for ambiguity and
representing qualitative relationships
was integral to the final result so I
want to do a somewhat technical deep
dive into that just because I think the
process behind deciding what the visual
framework would be as well as the
technology to use brought brought in a
lot of these questions that that I'll be
addressing first
so in order to just define my
terminology when I use the term
qualitative referring to data that's not
gathered in a numerical form it may be
gathered using descriptive open-ended or
unstructured techniques and will
typically have both comparative and
superlative forms as opposed to
classification which does not and of
course quantitative data by contrast is
gathered in a numerical form and can be
measured in a standard set of units
and when I use the term uncertainty I'm
referring to the level of confidence
explicitly associated with the values of
an attribute and uncertainty can come up
differently when working with
qualitative or quantitative data or
qualitative or quantitative variables
but in each context it's worth noting
that aggregation and categorization
implicitly introduce variability into a
data set that you're working with
irrespective of data quality and I'm not
acknowledging this type of uncertainty
to say that somehow raw data in its
messiest form should be visualized
rather I just want to foreground the
fact that processing data necessitates
imposing a semblance of order on what
can seem like a parent chaos
and that's in order to enable an analyst
or a researcher to discern visible
patterns or as it were make certain
patterns visible and I think that too
often we allow data to have an implicit
Authority when working with data that
focuses on attributes that are more
difficult to quantify the nature of
uncertainty becomes a messy process of
trying to smooth over the variability
associated with information that was
difficult to measure from the outset and
explicitly speaking uncertainty in its
most observable form surfaces as I
mentioned before in the confidence
associated with the values of an
attribute
finally when I use the term ambiguity
I'm referring to in exactness
qualitative data is ambiguous in the
sense that it captures information not
defined by a standardized set of units
uncertainty it's ambiguous because it
concerns the recorded value of a
variable that is known to be an estimate
a buffered range an abstraction or a
guess
despite the fact that data seems
explicitly ambiguous in fields such as
the humanities not to throw it onto the
bus which tends to be steeped in
mutability and nuance and interpretation
necessarily so keeping in mind the type
of space you build with a visualization
is a valuable thing to consider in any
context no matter how clearly predefined
and it's important to consider because
the space that we build constructs a
perspective for the viewer it determines
the information that the viewer sees the
scope of what they see and their
distance from the data itself which
includes any intermediary calculations
transformations or filtering that was
deemed necessary on the back end the
space we build also demark aids the
space within which we make an argument
and it's worth briefly touching on some
of the reasons this is prevalent
Jacques returns tome on information
design semiology of graphics is an
impressively exhaustive guide to the
graphical methods one can use to
represent differences within a data set
and patan is best known for introducing
the seven visual variables which are
location size value texture color
orientation and shape which can be used
to encode corresponding values in a
graphical context other visual variables
have since been added to this list but
these are the original and I would say
the handiest ones that I use most
frequently and despite my love for
patents methods and the frequency with
which I use them in my own work and
despite the argumentative benefits of
visual disambiguation that's proffered
by these variables graphical
categorization rests on re representing
the categories that data processing
implies to be distinct whether drawing
them further apart from one another or
drawing them closer together as need be
in order to convey something to the
viewer basically the visual elements you
use to illustrate the elements of a data
set paint the data set elements in
relation to one another and this isn't a
giant surprise and it's not necessarily
bad or even avoidable because people
write editorials like this that's how
things go but there's I believe an error
of this
automated comprehensiveness that
accompanies computationally generated
graphics which seems to superficially
distance the graphics themselves from
the intentions of the person who created
them and this consideration is not
limited to the web but it does seem that
the prevalence of interactive
visualization web-based or not in flex
our relationship to data in a manner
that paints data no matter the context
as self-evident and somehow less prone
to the fallibility that we would
associate with the human who gathered it
in the first place
simply speaking we're used to seeing
stable spaces which represent things to
us clearly and one thing I don't see as
much though which as I alluded to before
i do see more in the geo visualization
community in which we actually saw a
little bit of yesterday during the
keynote what I don't see as much is the
inclination to question their stability
in a critical way visualizations tend to
take the form of snackable content to
use a favorite and ridiculous agency
buzzword which basically means that they
often are artifacts that we can revisit
whenever we feel like grazing on
information we can put them down or pick
them up at will without too much effort
and they're satisfying because they show
us everything at once in all of its
complex glory
furthermore interactive visualizations
and power us to move things around and
to even control to an extent what we see
they gratify our need to understand data
as both a concept end as a material that
has the power to reveal things without
making evident they're messy Messier
roots
as visualization practitioners of course
we're inclined to choose clarity and
simplicity because that's the whole
point even if that entails downplaying
like the one messy outlier that keeps
trying to mess everything up or the
hoops we had to jump through in order to
get a messy incomplete data set to
appear complete given the few visual
variables we do have to play with an
element that differs from its peers will
stand out among elements that share the
same graphical plain and that's just the
nature of the spaces we build the spaces
that we work in have a way of calling
attention to anomalies for better or for
worse and normally if we're creating a
visualization for someone other than
ourselves we're creating it to support
an argument we're making however subtle
implicit conventional or overtly
contrarian that happens to be
there is a fair amount of talk about
scopic regimes and mapping and work
being done in the domain of critical and
feminist GIS and I don't plan to
explicitly address considerations of
power because there's a lot of good
literature on that already but I do want
to encourage a less stable understanding
of space both in geographic and
non-geographic contexts and I think that
one step forward in doing that is by
accommodating some of the messiness we
would normally try to subdue
so the question then becomes how might
we leverage bartends visual variables to
less rigidly demarcated space Alan McGee
grin has some thoughts on this
and if we focus solely on uncertainty
for the moment in Mickey Quinn's article
that specifically addresses visualizing
uncertainty which is appropriately
entitled visualizing on certain
information in States this that of
Britain's original graphic variables
size and value are most appropriate for
depicting uncertainty numerical
information well color hue Q shape and
perhaps orientation can be used for
uncertainty in nominal information and I
think the distinctions here are
interesting as a starting point they
don't comprise Mickey Cohen's entire
perspective but my first impression is
that using size and value to encode
something like an uncertainty score if
uncertainty is indeed recorded as a
continuous variable it makes sense since
one might normally employ these visual
variables to represent other continuous
variables such as magnitude or
population density on the other hand
though it doesn't seem to really offer
something different that evokes a sense
of less confidence when you look at this
admittedly very small but still clear
selection of shapes I mean looking at a
diagram like this I don't really assume
that either the top or the bottom
circles have anything implicitly open to
question about them
and I think that they leverage
properties that might be too
conventionally used for certain kinds of
values to be effective in addition I
like mceachran suggestion for nominal
information and think that there's
certainly a place for representing
uncertainty in this context as either an
ordinal value of binary value or again
as a four in particular given the visual
variables we might be leveraging to
distinguish categories of alien elements
orientation or shape seen the most
useful to employ alongside for example
color which we often use to distinguish
overarching categories but more than any
other part of the article the portion I
found most interesting was Mickey
Quinn's addition of focus as a variable
to play with which opens up what i think
are more possibilities for directly
evoking the uncertainty of a given value
by fuzzing out some of the very clearly
bound edges that
normally you would use to draw shapes
and I think that while these are
relatively often encountered in GIS
specific contexts they're certainly
applicable to non Geographic
visualization as well so a few different
approaches to altering the focus as a
variable within a visualization we of
course have Phil clarity here as one in
which the fill of a given element
differs from its contour based on the
uncertainty associated with its value
there's contour crispness which varies
the crispness or fuzziness of the
outline of a shape this is I pulled
McKeon's somewhat low res
representations here but I think they do
the job
and another one he mentions is fog which
I have mixed feelings about but which I
included for good measure nonetheless in
this case we had a hazy layer between
the viewer and the visualization itself
and while this technique does not
directly alter elements on the page or
the screen as it were it does add a
foggy barrier between you and it which
suggests that there's something you
cannot see as clearly as the rest
so these are a few different directions
to take that I think are not commonplace
but often seen in in mapping but I don't
come across these as much in
non-geographic visualization
if we turn back to the data side the
biggest issue to deal with is how to
quantify non-quantitative concepts you
want to represent and I mean that in a
very utilitarian sense if you are
constructing a graphic that will
represent elements with certain act on
certain attributes some measure needs to
determine the level of fuzziness for
example in the outline of an element or
the extents of the foggy region you plan
to impose on your graphic at some point
we need to reduce ambiguous values to
numbers in order to work with them
computationally and to make a
qualitative variable a quantitative one
may simply entail converting it into a
measurable value based on your knowledge
of the subject and this is an approach
that i and the team i worked with took
for the graphic i'm going to walk
through in a minute
and in terms of uncertainty my go-to
approach and I think many people go to
approach is to just make uncertainty
itself into a variable and which enables
you to then visually encode that level
of confidence associated with a value in
some of the ways maybe that McGee kryn
discussed and then you can go from there
and finally I just wanted to give a
brief nod to interactivity though I
myself haven't experiment experimented
as much with ways to play with
interaction or animation to to
accommodate uncertainty or ambiguity
interactivity does bring with it the
potential for motion as well as for
interesting user feedback which again we
did leverage tiny bit of that in the
product i'm going to talk about but a
few potential routes to explore on the
animation front might involve playing
with speed or frequency or flicker or
direction i mean there are a lot of
possibilities but it's it's a new
dimension a new malleable dimension
that's interesting to explore
there's also a question which we touched
upon yesterday regarding annotation and
the type of legend that's appropriate to
include an interactive and while I'm not
by any means and authority on what
should be prevented to or what should be
presented to a user who first account as
an interactive graphic or what a user
might need to know upon immediately
navigating to a visualization I do
believe that of course citing sources as
well as explicitly providing information
regarding data processing encourage a
healthy skepticism within visual
representation though of course that's
that tends to not be the number one
priority of a visualization maker but
nonetheless it's a good sentiment to put
out there I think
so I want to turn now to the project I
mentioned which will provide a better
walk through on one way to deal with a
question of qualitative relationships
so towards the end of last summer I
worked with quantum magazine which is an
editorially independent publication of
the Simons Foundation to create a
representation of the theories of
everything which was essentially all of
the major topics and physics and the
theories associated with each topic as
well as the relationships and overlaps
between the topics themselves and the
interconnectivity between theories and
the broader aim of the project was to
create a graphic that could both tied
together the content of the website as
in include links to articles that were
published over the life span of the
publication but which might address
related things despite how far apart
they were in time and serve as a fun
educational reference for readers which
would grow in complexity as the site
added additional content
and one less than great aspect of this
that I should just note is that
technical constraints prevented us from
making this iframe too graphic a sort of
automated aggregator of information on
the site which I think would have
leveled it up everything did have to be
hard-coded but that turned out to not be
a huge issue because the major topics in
physics have been pretty persistent and
will likely continue to be and then the
theories the way the theories were built
into the interactive would enable the
updating of the data set down the road
if if need be
so really the most difficult aspect of
the project was in representing topics
that had no distinct size for
standardized measure of significance
these numbers don't seem very big
but if you have I'll show the data in
its original form in a second but if you
just if you have a list of topics
and the knowledge that some are more
talked about or focused on than others
and you have a glee see them as
umbrellas over different types of
theories it can be a really difficult
set of conceptual challenges to grapple
with especially when you're trying to
make something so so vague in a data
sense very concrete and explorable each
of these topics had any number of
theories associated with it and there
was a hierarchy between them in that
topics contained theories and the
interrelationships between theories and
topics needed separate methods of
representation because this is going to
get very excessively specific but it's
maybe will be clear looking at the
graphic itself topic relationships did
not always have a real bearing on theory
relationships the theories that were
contained within them two theories
within a topic might be related to
theories within other topics but not to
each other for instance
because that theory and other theories
had their roots in a single other theory
so you know it wasn't it wasn't the kind
of thing where the topic a theory was
associated with would determine its
relationship to other theories and you
couldn't assume that it had that there
were direct linkages between theories
contained in broader topics
so
here's what the original data look like
which was a fun collection of
descriptive paragraphs in a word
document actually like a completely
nightmarish representation of topics
and basically the furthest left indented
blocks of grey text our topics and
nected blocks of great text are the
theories associated with that topic
there were a couple cases in which there
were duplicates were different versions
of the same theory for example might
show up under two different topics
and if you're working with Theory IDs
for example that necessitated having an
extra layer of
of intelligence to the interactive
itself but basically this was all the
content that you needed to make it into
this final interactive text included
because we not only wanted to provide a
picture of what fits executed looked
like we wanted to be able to engage
readers by explaining in some depth what
each one was
thankfully word count limitations but so
it was
quite a bit
it took a while to come up with a way to
fold all of this away in a meaningful
elegant way
so I'd mentioned the problem of topics
eyes before he recalled a 12 topics and
that starts slide I showed a few slides
earlier topic size we ended up dealing
with by making topic significance into a
variable as well as this secondary both
technical and conceptual problem of
overlap between topics we created two
different days data sets one in which
topics were just listed out with a value
for significance and then another in
which any topics that were related in a
certain way would be would be linked
together and given a score of degree of
overlap
so that was an iterative process that
involved talking to a lot of scientists
and researchers and just coming up with
the semblance of a list that everyone
could agree on
but since since each of those each of
those variables were essentially
qualitative in order for me to take them
and feed them into some sort of
web-based graphic they had to have
values from youtube and just as a
diversion for anyone interested I ended
up I built all of this in d3 so deeply
what's my go-to from the beginning and
while it wasn't clear at the outset
whether or not we would be able to use
an out-of-the-box graphic I was
gravitating towards the fourth directed
graph if anyone's used it before and the
final product ended up being a very
hacked version of a few of those so
that's just that's just some background
the graphic itself was not claiming in
any way to be the be-all and all of the
field or to represent the entirety of
the physics world in a way that was
impervious to dispute but it did seek to
be as comprehensive and as accurate as
possible and we tried to make that clear
in the accompanying article in the
article accompanying the interactive so
rather than annotate all of that within
the interactive itself we relied on the
text of the article to to make that
clear
so I'm going to show my very very very
first pass at this which is hideous but
there you go I used like okay so this is
at this point we scored every topic in
physics on a scale I think of 1 to 20
say so every topic here was I guess
quantum gravity probably had a score of
18 or something the size of each circle
just pulled directly from whatever that
value was
and I think I used some vaguely dc-based
Venn diagram generator her for this kind
of just to see what it would do with the
overlaps I defined and I guess somewhere
in there it was clearly reading what the
relationships between these topics were
but I mean like the like the strong CP
bubble down there it appears nested
within these bigger circles and it's
just I mean it's an unreadable mess
basically and I think that was largely
in part due to the circle as a shape
which isn't so flexible in terms of
being able to overlap other surrounding
shapes this made it clear that we really
needed something more malleable but
working with in SVG
as were and it safely is very conducive
to makes malleability difficult to code
a second reflex was to resort to a node
link diagram here because if you think
about it it makes it makes sense you
have a series of nodes of varying
degrees of significance and you have
relationships between them that you'd
like to account for and taking a network
approach would both give you the terrain
and account for links between between
different topics you could also size by
radius as it were and there were a
couple of if you put this that I wasn't
super comfortable with right off the bat
and the main one was aside from its
oversimplification I didn't like the
fact that the relationship between these
two topics was represented as its own
discrete shape we've really wanted to
evoke a sense of overlapping topics even
in a very literal way and this seemed
detached and didn't really enable us to
encode strength or closeness yes we
could have varied the line with for
example to maybe make some relationships
heavier than others but it was a limited
a limited approach but I tried it anyway
just as a starting point and this was
this was a first attempt to represent
all of these topics and their
relationships using the d3 force
directed graph and it's fine in that I
mean this was especially useful because
it generated a smart layout that spaced
things out in a way that would have
taken forever to do manually without
without breaking my display I want to
just quickly pull up the force directed
graph in deeply for those who haven't
seen it before
it's like this it's got it's a nice
built in physics and it you can you can
vary the amount of repulsion between
nodes so that you can have this help you
generate a nicely spaced out network
that would be a pain to do if you were
if you were doing it manually so this
was the initial initial lay of the land
and it wasn't suitable for our purposes
but around this time the problem of
overlaps started to become really
started to to worry me because
drawing a path dynamically like this
I don't know I went through I went
through a number of different approaches
including you know extrapolating
neighbor nodes from some like Delano
triangulation set up and some of the
models i came up with before deciding on
this final method would generate
properly in the browser maybe ninety
five percent of the time but that x 25
percent a topic would not overlap a
topic it was supposed to or a theory
would fall outside of the graphic itself
and none of the methods that i tried out
in this somewhat limited bounded SVG
world were really sustainable or getting
confidence i guess but finally given the
the overlap metric as well as the
significance one i came up with this
sort of deal where
I would use the d3 generated link
between nodes as a sort of measuring
stick from which to draw as you would a
compass from which to determine the
vertex of a line I would draw around
each node so that way I could both
control how big i know it appeared in
this vague shape I was drawing around it
and I could to a certain extent control
the degree of overlap between nodes
so I don't know if that's true or not
but for quantum gravity
assuming it had a very assuming it was
supposed to look big in this app I could
take it significant score and then
knowing that this link what
entirety problem I could take the
overlap score between though
calculation and decide that that point
best place to put a vertex for the whole
surrounding that note
diversity I can do that for the higher
than problem as well
solution the car
the network has a skeleton I had all of
these like pre spaced lines accounting
for every relationship and I guess we
were lucky in the sense that there were
no really really bizarre over the house
and that I didn't have to worry about
drawing a shape that would be like you
know ridiculous I'm coming around the
whole thing we were lucky in that it
could be pretty self-contained and that
this method would give us what we needed
while still leveraging the built-in
functionality of the force directed
graph so here is an initial the initial
stage of the bag you obviously can still
see network diagram
but also I mean
yeah you can you can sort of see how I
would
in the links emanating from
two
two drawings
blobby or shapes around the perfect
circles
and it took some trial and error in
terms of over representing or under
representing certain things but it
turned out to be turned out to be a good
solution
this is another snapshot of a pretty
ugly pass an interface if you remember
from the word doc there was lots of text
to deal with you
just had it on their individual feedback
for me to make sure that everything is
going love correct correctly it sort of
aligned it around the
the body and visualization like this but
it was way too busy for them for the
final product
you can also see here this internal
network
using to represent theories within
topics this is yet another deep repost
overlay on top of the original one the
original one which had the lines drawn
i was able to use
y coordinates of those topic nodes and
set them as little like gravitational
focus points for the overlay
force directed graph so I could use the
underneath to get theories
to hover around the topic they were
and that wasn't perfect because
occasionally gave rise to this life eggs
in a basket kind of view which nobody
speaks that much but at the end of the
day it oh yeah this image shows that
more clearly it turned out to be
unnecessary well a pretty necessary
compromise in the long run oh you'll
also see how on edge cases like topics
that edge cases like this topics along
the edge that didn't have any
relationships going this way that would
help draw the shape I had to put in
don't be buffered
to get the shape to draw properly but
that's getting excessively detailed so
the final version is look like this and
I'll pull it up live now so you can get
the full experience this was art
directed by LNS Mahalo who is a quanta
employee and
the gradient in the background was
simply to create a space so it's not
symbolic of anything so my local version
and adding to this adding this kind of
fisheye effect to it you could zoom in
to a given topic the sub theory nodes
will kind of rearrange themselves in it
in a browsable list and you could click
on those in addition to get a
description on the right
and as far as just programmatically
handling the kind of data we were
working with this you know I was I was
happy with the setup despite occasional
busyness or overlapping of nodes when
you're working with something with an
unpredictable physics simulation some
weirdness will come to the fore um and
it does a little bit here but all in all
it's a pretty nice way I think to browse
what started off as a really difficult
quantity of information to delve into
and finally there are certainly
weaknesses with this visualization
you'll notice that in some previous
versions I did retain the dotted line
outline for topics which would seem
right since there since they're not
clearly defined by by standardized units
ultimately this was just a design
decision to to to make them solid but we
hoped the mutability and the lobby pneus
that the of the visualization as a whole
what sort of enforced that these shapes
were not fixed so for better or for
worse that's that's what that is
and I mean
SBG as a whole is not especially
conducive to
to building big things because it's
based in ratios and whatnot one little
piece of the interface here that I might
as well just address this isn't true in
my in my local coffee but we did end up
adding in up voting which was a weird
I I thought it was a weird thing to add
to agree
a strange way to empower any users who
might be browsing it but ultimately the
idea was to allow readers to vote on
their favorite theories and perhaps
construct a leaderboard of some sort so
within the topics the little theories
down here will order based on the number
of votes they have but that's a little
subtle thing I Dilton so but now you
know now it's there any of the links on
the sides lead to articles where you can
read more about a given theory or topic
and
that's
pretty much covers it
yeah I can use the rest of my time to
take any questions and one has
no question
people trying to
produce a network
relatedness between these different
well as you'd like to
so if you could
I understand with
both species in
you Jews have
histories and
then there are things like
ornithology trans
yeah so this is
chips
the bottom
I'm just wondering
parts of things you will do it
right to that and also whether or not
you could take a sort of simplistic
why can't we based approach based on the
similarity of experience
it was a 21
uh 41 I think I like split them up and
turn volume recount
Paschal mystery
that was kind of
really
yeah no I mean I would definitely add a
level of granularity
and I want her to given the admittedly
simple hierarchies does represent
that sounds like a different
visualization perfectly that sounds like
something I wouldn't necessarily want to
put in here because it would be imposing
a different temper a Latina pond
something that didn't really have one
before them
but depending on you know depending on
the time
connoisseur that'll
I think that would be
great perspective to take I feel like it
would not look like this though it is
that writable you know it would be it
would be completely different it would
be more directional this this is just
kind of floating here though it's like
the static state of things you know if I
were if I were going to emphasize
progression or temporalities more I
would certainly have this appear to be
more of a
but